we say hello friend to our friend jim
nance once again how are you jim
i am still on such a high i thankfully
got a little rest last night
to get reloaded and prepared for
tonight's follow-up to that but
man it feels so good to to be here in
indianapolis to have the championship
game tonight the masters this week and
thanks for replaying that call you know
every time i hear it i've only heard it
a handful of times i
i pick up on a little thing here and
there and
i heard raft uh just a moment ago to say
something about with a little kiss and i
i remember coming back now on the
broadcast because i haven't
obviously watched the broadcast again
right did say within seconds of that
wrapped that's the biggest kiss you've
ever seen in your basketball career
and he agreed that of course it was a
bank shot it's a kiss
and we we you know jim use we we do
throw around
the terms instant classic quite a bit
because you know certainly in this day
and age
last year plus that we we're we're we're
we're hungry for it we're hungry for
those moments where
you know i was telling the story i'm
sitting with my ten-year-old son i
demanded he put his ipad down to watch
overtime
and um you know and and we both you know
uh
got up off the the couch together and uh
this truly was however an instant
classic where
where does this rank for you jim
well i think for me uh in terms of games
that i've ever
called i think it's the best one i've
ever called in basketball
and i think that it's going to rank
overall as
maybe maybe the greatest basketball game
of the modern era now i don't have the
data points to go back
and look at 1957 north carolina and
kansas with will chamberlain going to
three overtimes in the championship game
i don't have that i wasn't born yet
but i i think that this just barely
nudges ahead of duke kentucky the later
shot
at the very least it's this generation's
later moment
the shot was longer this
this this was to get into the
championship game christian shot was to
get into the final four
i will give you the christian's shot had
everything riding on it because duke was
down a point when he when he
when he took it so um yeah it's
listen it's hard to come up with
anything that you could say was better
than that
uh that anybody that's listening right
now has ever seen
in terms of college basketball
excitement well in terms of also the
the backstory um obviously duke and
kentucky blew bloods
um at the time or you know obviously
shishevsky was
um definitely building something to say
the least
and had already built something you know
here it's kind of role reversal right
the blue blood of ucla
is got the glass slipper and gonzaga
has the his chance at history here and
that too just ucla's journey to this
point
as well and how well they were playing
my god i don't i don't know if that game
obviously if that had rimmed out or not
gone in we wouldn't be talking about
ucla and baylor
tonight jim for for real well
how about the the charge call with 0.7
seconds to go in overtime
the entire game
rested in the hands of the official if
he calls that a block call
yeah you're sending to the line with
seven ten
tenths of a second to go and makes one
free throw
you know ucla is going to be in the
championship game i mean they called it
a charge
so i mean the game the split second
difference here and there
is just amazing and i i just i'm just so
happy to be able to share it with grant
and raft
we have such a fun time together the
three of us uh
unfortunately with the protocols and all
we haven't had our normal
march togetherness we haven't had a meal
together we have been allowed to leave
our rooms except to go to the games
so we've been here for four weeks going
back to the big ten tournament
and the four walls are closing in on me
here a little bit
i i can't wait for the game tonight and
then hop on a plane and get to a gun
store i can spend a lot of time outdoors
by the way i i couldn't imagine a better
place to break
quarantine than augusta national gym
well they're still quarantined
i'm sure you will there there are
bubbles but it it is
definitely a little more freedom to move
around you could go outside and
you will be outside for 12 to 14 hours a
day
so um that that i relish and look
forward to
but uh just to to have that moment i
and when you're calling a game like that
uh
and everybody has their own style and
approach to it
in my style whether i'm working with
romo on football working with tony
um or i'm working with grant and and
bill on baskets i want to give them room
or foul do on golf
i want them to be able to have the
freedom to be themselves
and not be overly territorial about it
it's a visual medium
i like being a conversational
play-by-play guy
versus a guy who's identifying every
pass rebound and
and shot anybody can do that and and
so i like to get into the discussion
arena
and and bring with it context
perspective and framing
in terms of history so what i heard just
hear you guys play it back what was a
reaction
that probably was very similar to what
was going on in the eyes and living room
you know with the ipad put down you and
your son were probably
jumping up and down and hugging and
rolling on the floor
we were pretty close to doing that
ourselves we we were
talking at the same time which is okay i
mean at the moment you can't script it
and um i i was proud to be able to set
it up that gonzaga had
time to do something and for the win and
then you know we all reacted the way we
should and again it's not maybe
classical stand-alone play-by-play guy i
wouldn't want it that way
i'm a team guy and i like the shared
moment and
to be able to then get it back and and
and within
three seconds i would be able to say
that that gonzaga's perfect season is
still intact
it's still on go um i'm really proud of
that
that that orchestration between the
three of us that we got so much in there
and
you have no idea something like that's
gonna happen and
it's uh it's epic i mean that suggs will
he's gonna go on and have uh
i'm sure he'll he'll be one of the first
picks in the draft this year
and he'll go on and have a fabulous
career you can tell the kids
super talented but i don't care what he
does
he's always going to be reminded of that
shot that shot's going to be
something he's going to be wearing with
him as far as pride for the rest of his
for the rest of his years jim nance here
on the rich eisen show and i'm i'm
wondering if
and i i i understand what i'm about to
say sounds like hyperbole
out on its face but hopefully everyone
will hear me out here is i'm wondering
if this is one of those
sports moments like the miracle on ice
like the buckner play where everyone
years from now will assume it was for
the championship
and it was not and that there's a very
good point there's another
game and that's tonight
and um i i'm i'm i'm wondering if that
is going to be
potentially a factor this evening jim
what do you think
well you've got to come back to earth
that's for sure if you're gonzaga and
that happened almost at the
strike of midnight uh
on on saturday night so you've got uh
you got a really quick turnaround
physically and
even more importantly emotionally and
baylor is
so good it's so it's really
indecipherable to me to tell you
which team's better or just to try to
find the difference between the two of
them so
uh it was workmanlike and unmemorable
really uh the way baylor dominated
my alma mater houston on saturday they
mean
they were clearly the better team and
that's who they are and that's how
they're going to play tonight
so i do think this i do think
if you if you want to say pay it off if
you want that moment
to have the the the legs that you spoke
up miracle on ice
the buckner play um well i'm gonna more
directly associate it with with the usa
russia
and then coming back and playing finland
yep people forget they had to play
finland for the championship
right um so um because the
russia game was in the semi-finals and
uh yeah i i mentioned to
mark pew last night i actually made this
same
parallel looking for context and i said
you know you guys have got to come back
and you got to do the equivalent you've
got to be
like like the usa hockey team did you
got to see finland he said
jim baylor's a lot better than finland
you know what you know i'm going to use
that line tonight go for it but of
course
there's no question about that give it
to you first my man like you got it
first
i will take the gymnast exclusive and
run with it um
and and make sure everybody understands
that when when they hear that tonight on
cbs
and you know you're your great friend um
al michaels on the call of
of that you know back in 1980 he tells
the story and maybe this is something
mark few can take the page
out of her brooks he said her brooks
told the team but
you know in the intermission down 2-1
going into the third period against
finland
you lose this you'll take this to your
graves like
that that everything that happened
before now obviously
that might be something particularly
signifi uh strenuous to say to
to a bunch of youngsters but so were
those kids at team usa
i i you know i it is something tonight
that baylor could use to its advantage
saying okay
everybody's sleeping on us we just blew
out houston and let's go
and i'm wondering what you think the
matchup looks like tonight what do you
what are you what are you guys talking
about in your meetings
if gonzaga has its legs rich uh
this should be up and down the floor
kind of like the ucla game was we're
talking about the highest scoring team
college basketball this year
in gonzaga baylor is the i believe the
sixth highest
scoring team baylor's the best field uh
baylor has the best three-point field
goal percentage gonzaga has the best
overall field goal percentage
they make shots they take shots quickly
they're up and down the floor
i mean i think the game is just going to
be great we've wanted this game all year
long
it took four months for it to happen
they were here in this very city on
december the 5th
and 90 minutes before the game the game
got shut down because a
member of the basketball delegation for
the zags and the player
tested positive in the marion county
this is a marion county
town here the health commissioner closed
down the game that was cbs's season
opener
and now it'll be it'll be cbs's season
ender
and it's just four months to the day
later here we go and it's interesting
the game
was actually programmed in concert with
someone at cbs nick bess
uh barnes she's she's remarkable she's
programmer puts a lot of our
our uh our basketball schedule together
with the
uh with dan weinberg through great parts
he bets you never hear about them
other programmers they have unbelievable
relationships
and they got together and thought well
these two teams going to be one and two
and and then scott and mark scott drew
and mark few are
great pals and they said we need to do
this because college basketball needs us
to do this
we didn't have a tournament last year we
need to do this because that's what's
right for the game
so they scheduled the game all those
folks got
together hooked up on the phone and the
game never happened
as it turns out as fate would have it it
does actually happen
it happens on the last game of the
season
and again it's just a sense of normalcy
that uh we're thrilled to see even
though the
the stands are clearly abnormal and and
um
and and it's just as it just the fact
that the tournament's going off and
and is ending tonight you know knocking
on wood without without the proverbial
hitch we're we're all
pleased to see it and then you jim nance
head off to
uh augusta national what do you think
the story of the week
at augusta national is going to be with
the masters back
in april well the first two or three
days that i'll be at augusta the main
thing
as far as the story that i'll be in
conversation with with the players
doesn't matter who it will be
will be the subs shot oh that's all
they're going to talk to me about
i know they're all watching it happens
every year i try to
transition try to get into their minds
and start rounding up some
fresh information on the world's top
players and
invariably they want to talk to me about
the ncaa tournament
so uh that will be the story for a
couple more days
but the story of the golf event will be
back five months later just if actually
one week shy of five months
it's that quickly turned around on the
calendar you've got
dj dustin johnson going for two green
jackets
in that span can he do it you got jordan
spieth
riding high all roads have been leading
to him winning
bless him he did it yesterday i mean
it's just fantastic
to see uh all of that go away all that
talk and chatter about how he can't
he can't he's done whatever the
mean-spirited stuff that was
heaped on his shoulders that's behind
him now he comes to a place where he's
not only one
he's finished second a couple of times
he knows how to get around augusta
that's going to be a great story and who
knows what else you still got out there
mcilroy who has been a little bit off
lately
and has made a swing coaching change uh
he's going for the career grand slam you
forget that that's like his
third or fourth attempt at going for the
career grand slam
so there's an abundance of stories uh i
can't wait to identify him
can't wait to uh to drop in and um
and just get lost in the moment uh down
down in augusta
and you know it's monday of championship
night and the start of masters week is
always one of the most fascinating days
of my year probably the most fascinating
because you've got the excitement that
jitters the anticipation of what's about
to happen tonight
you're about to call your 15th game in
23 days
you've prepared you've talked to
everybody you're going to walk into that
arena and realize all that
history that's on the line meantime i'm
packing up
i'm putting stuff in boxes to ship home
i bought so much stuff that basically
had an apartment
since i was wasn't really able to to
barely leave
my room and um you know so i'm into
logistics
i'm into trying to have this in my head
tonight the grandeur of it
get some thoughts in my head about the
framing of this moment tonight
whichever way it goes and then next
thing you know tomorrow i landed a gust
it's 84 degrees and and
um you know i'm at this place that i can
only dream of as a little boy
and i never take it for granted it's
amazing jim it's just truly remarkable
and of course you know life is so damn
short as we saw with tiger just a couple
of weeks ago what what do you hear about
him i'm sure there'll be a lot of
conversation about him
uh certainly at one point during the
broadcast are you hearing anything about
his recovery
right now no it's been on really truly
it's been
that that that information has been held
pretty tight and that's just the way
tiger wants that as you know i had the
last interview with tiger
some 36 hours before his accident
he joined me on the air in the final
round at riviera
for the genesis open he was kind enough
to uh
to to to hang in there for 12 minutes
and
well i got to tell you the story i've
got to tell you this story okay
so you check in with with with someone
that
is going to join you during a commercial
break you make sure their headset's on
can they hear you are their levels good
this and that so we had the profuncr hey
tiger how you doing can you hear me good
yeah okay
hey congratulations you know this was an
anniversary year for his tiger woods
foundation
checked in hey can you stay for a while
we're going to try to bob and weave the
interview in with some live golf good
i'm good
i've got all kinds of time great i'll do
a segment with you guys perfect stand by
here we go
so now next thing interview on the air
and you know you're asking tiger
questions about his foundation and how
it's his help and then i started to get
into is he coming back for augusta and
again
we cut away a few times and he's still
talking over some of the important shots
were
with max homa and all the contenders
were taking place
now it comes time to say goodbye and one
of the last things i asked him would we
see him in augusta seven weeks from now
he said god willing i'll be there which
is a little eerie now that you hear it
and then i said would you play a
tournament running up to it just to have
a
a rep he said you know all that don't
know i'm waiting to see what the doctors
say
well tag your thanks for being with us
and it's great to see you again we hope
to see you down in augusta at that time
seller shy our our our steam producer
puts up a graphic
that shows sam snead 82 tiger woods 82
wins
jack nicholas 73 so this panel is on the
on the screen so i'm reacting to it so i
look at it
again just recall whatever my a sense of
history that blessed
with by the man upstairs and i'm
grateful for that i said
hey tiger take a look at this so i just
said tiger thanks for being with us hey
you got it oh tiger take a look at this
there you are with sam state 82 wins
and here's a story that maybe you don't
even know
that when you first debuted on the pga
tour as a 16 year old
sam snead was the tournament honoree
that
that week in 92 here riviera
he was on the program they had an oil
painting
uh presentation inside the clubhouse and
when you played
sam snead came down the hill and watched
you play the entire tenth hole he was in
your gallery
behind the ropes he stood behind you
when you hit your tee shot off of 11
and then made his way back up the hill
to the clubhouse and who could have ever
known that that day
there would be this faithful confluence
of
sam snead and tiger woods two guys that
are now linked with
82 wins all time it's an amazing story
and about that time um steve milton our
our director said jim jim hold on a
minute
we're in commercial i said wait what do
you mean he said those sellers
linked to you went down we went to
commercial a long time ago
i i i said what about this whole story i
just
i just dropped on tiger about about
samsa's
nobody at home heard a word of it we we
left when you said thanks tagger for
being with us
and all of a sudden tiger comes on and
says wait a minute
wait a minute none of that ever got on
the air yeah
milton says none of it not a word tiger
says i'm like
man that's too bad that was some really
good you know what
really good stuff okay that was the
really good stuff
that was unbelievable he said how did
you know that i said
you know i actually had written a story
a few years ago on golf digest about it
researched it
found it in some some files and um
he said man i wish you guys would come
back with that and of course you come
back you got to get back to covering the
golf tournament i thanked him but that
was the last thing
that he said he was so bummed that that
story about sam snead following him
around
uh uh two holes in competition when he
was a 16 year old
uh it didn't it didn't make the light of
air
as we say it was we were gone well maybe
you could tell the story at some point
during the during the masters giving him
a shout out i'm sure he'll be out there
watching what
i will definitely sure have several
moments where we will
be bringing up tiger i mean after all
when again you're dealing with history
and context
there's hardly anything around there
that doesn't remind you of a feat
of tigers in the past so you can't plan
it
it's a reactionary thing we're there to
show golf
and it's i'm sure any number of times
there will be
an occasion where there's a shot that
similar to something he's pulled off
before or some historical context
uh that that i'll need to make the
parallel with tiger and a given player
uh for this week so we wish him well i
wish i had an update for you
um i'll just say this i have
nothing to base this on except having a
pretty good understanding of what's
inside that man's heart i've been around
him for the great majority of his 82
wins
high 50s i think it's 57 or so wins
maybe something like that
i know i've been for nine of his 15
majors on on the call walking up the
18th
i can't speak to his uh his x-rays
his surgeries i can only speak to his
heart
and if there's anyone that could ever
come back from this
i'm betting on tiger and i don't think
we've seen the last of them
you're the best jim nance truly
appreciate it have a great time tonight
have a great masters week hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here